Letzte Woche
lief mein "Reporter"-Film
"Albtraum Südafrika -
Weisse Farmer fliehen".
Das löste viele Reaktionen aus:
sehr viele Likes auf YouTube, aber
auch einige kritische Kommentare.
Dazu nehme ich jetzt gern Stellung.
Jemand schreibt z.B.:
"Hier geht es
um Rassismus gegen Weisse."
Oder jemand anderes:
"Ach ja, und dann gibt es Leute,
die meinen,
Rassismus gegen Weisse
gäbe es nicht."
Im Film geht es v.a. darum,
dass vor 30 Jahren
Nelson Mandela
aus Robben Island entlassen wurde.
Ein Ereignis
von welthistorischer Bedeutung.
Er hatte einen grossen Traum:
die Rainbow Nation,
die in Frieden mit sich selbst
und der Welt lebt.
Die Idee war, zu schauen,
was aus diesem Traum
von Nelson Mandela geworden ist.
Das haben wir v.a.
mit zwei Aspekten behandelt.
Das eine ist die Landfrage, die sich
schon nach der Apartheid stellte.
Was macht man mit der
sehr ungerechten Verteilung von Land?
Nelson Mandela
setzte auf Freiwilligkeit, sagte,
ein williger Käufer und ein williger
Verkäufer würden sich finden,
es würde sich irgendwie regeln
mit der Zeit.
Heute stellt man fest:
Das ist nicht der Fall.
Es sind immer noch ca. 70 %
der landwirtschaftlichen Flächen
in den Händen der weissen Minderheit.
Jetzt stellt sich die Frage,
wie man damit umgeht.
Jetzt hat es in Südafrika
einen Umschwung gegeben.
Mittlerweile fordert
die ANC-Regierung eine Landreform.
Das könnte konkret bedeuten,
dass man weissen Farmern
das Land wegnehmen könnte,
dass man sie enteignen könnte und
auch nichts dafür bezahlen müsste,
keine Kompensation leisten müsste.
Dieses Land
würde man dann Schwarzen geben.
Eine komplette Änderung dessen,
was sich Nelson Mandela
vor 30 Jahren vorstellte.
Das ist der erste Punkt.
Der zweite, der mich interessiert
hat, ist die Kriminalität.
Wenn die Regenbogennation
in Frieden mit sich selbst
und der Welt leben möchte,
wie steht es dann
mit der Kriminalität?
Diese hat enorm zugenommen.
V.a. auch weisse Farmer
fühlen sich extrem bedroht.
Sie haben das Gefühl,
das richte sich v.a. gegen sie,
sie würden richtiggehend dezimiert.
Uns hat interessiert,
ob da etwas dran ist.
Wir haben einerseits mit
weissen Farmern darüber gesprochen,
aber auch mit Gareth Newham, der sich
wissenschaftlich damit befasst,
der zu diesem Thema forscht.
Er sagt, es gebe keinen Zusammenhang
mit der Hautfarbe.
Er sagt, die Kriminalität steige
allgemein und betreffe auch alle.
Besonders gefährdet
seien Mittelstandsfamilien,
Schwarze in urbanen Gebieten.
Es sei nicht so, dass v.a. Weisse in
ländlichen Gebieten betroffen wären.
Das sind die zwei grossen Themen,
die der Film behandelt hat.
Jemand anderes schreibt:
"Hier bleibt hauptsächlich
ein nicht mehr zeitgemässes
Schwarz-Weiss-Bild hängen,
das sich auch
in den teils ekelerregenden
Kommentaren widerspiegelt."
Wenn bei Ihnen ein ekelerregendes
Schwarz-Weiss-Bild hängen bleibt,
tut mir das sehr leid.
Die Absicht war eine andere.
Die Absicht war, zu schauen,
was 30 Jahre nach der Freilassung
von Nelson Mandela
aus seinem Traum geworden ist.
Ich finde, das haben wir
differenziert abgehandelt.
Es gibt spannende Einordnungen,
gerade von Gareth Newham,
zur ganzen Problematik
der steigenden Kriminalität
und wen sie v.a. betrifft.
Ich finde,
wir waren sehr differenziert.
Man findet durchaus Antworten,
die das klischierte
Schwarz-Weiss-Bild aufbrechen.
Jemand schreibt: "Die wichtigste
Frage wurde hier nicht gestellt:
Wie kamen diese weissen Farmer
damals zu ihrem Land?"
Die weissen Schweizer Farmer im Film
haben ihr Land rechtmässig erworben.
Was heisst rechtmässig?
Sie haben es zur Zeit,
als sie es gekauft haben,
nach geltendem Recht,
nach geltendem Gesetz gekauft.
Die grosse und spannende Frage
ist natürlich:
Welchen Wert hat das heute noch?
Wir gehen von Folgendem aus:
Als die Apartheid aufgehört hat,
sagte Nelson Mandela,
das gelte weiter, diese Menschen
konnten ihr Land behalten.
Sie hatten es schon vorher erworben.
Jetzt stellt sich die Frage,
wie das weitergeht.
Gibt es eine Änderung im Gesetz,
gibt es plötzlich die Möglichkeit,
ihnen das Land wegzunehmen,
ohne ihnen etwas dafür zu bezahlen?
Die Antwort auf diese Frage
ist einfach:
Sie haben es damals nach
geltendem Recht und Gesetz gekauft.
Jemand schreibt:
"Es gibt keine Beweise dafür,
dass sie zu Zielen werden,
weil sie weisse Farmer sind."
"Na, dann werden im gleichen Masse
auch schwarze Farmer ermordet?"
Ja, das ist so, es werden auch
schwarze Farmer ermordet.
Wir hätten auch
mit schwarzen Farmern reden wollen.
Auch sie haben Angst,
auch sie werden überfallen,
auch ihnen wird Vieh gestohlen,
wie weissen Farmern.
Wir hatten entsprechende Drehtermine
vereinbart.
Das Problem war, dass ich
im März 2020 in Südafrika war.
Dann ging die ganze Corona-Geschichte
in Südafrika richtig los.
Ich musste die Dreharbeiten
frühzeitig abbrechen.
Ein lokaler Mitarbeiter
filmte noch weiter,
Dinge, die schon vereinbart waren.
Auch mit den schwarzen Farmern
hätte er noch filmen sollten.
Sie wollten aber nicht mehr,
hatten Angst
vor einer Corona-Übertragung
und sagten die Termine ab.
Es wären aber auch Aufnahmen mit
schwarzen Farmern geplant gewesen.
Dann schreibt Diego Costa:
"Nicht ganz gelungen."
"Was wollt ihr
mit der Doku überhaupt sagen?"
"Irgendwie ziemlich schräg
und polarisierend. War das Absicht?"
"Der content
wirkt etwas strukturlos."
"Alles sehr verwirrend
und spielt irgendwie
den Rechtspopulisten hier auf YouTube
in die Hände."
Ich muss ehrlich sagen:
Ich kann nicht ganz nachvollziehen,
wieso das Rechtspopulisten
in die Hände spielen sollte.
Ich glaube, wir haben differenziert
zwei Fragen betrachtet,
die uns interessierten:
Wie ist die Verteilung von Land
und wie ist es mit der Kriminalität?
Gerade bei der Kriminalität
haben wir mit Gareth Newham
einen ausgewiesenen Experten,
der das Ganze
sehr differenziert eingeordnet hat.
Das Wichtigste ist, ob ich
nach bestem Wissen und Gewissen
eine Geschichte erzählen kann,
von der ich das Gefühl habe:
Sie ist richtig, es stimmt.
Ich war vor Ort, ohne Vorurteile
auf die eine oder andere Seite.
Ich will nichts beweisen, ich will
nicht jemandem in die Hände spielen
und jemand anderem nicht.
Ich gehe dorthin, schaue,
was ich sehe, und berichte darüber.
"Es ist wichtig, eine solche
Reportage in einen Kontext zu setzen,
was mir hier fehlt",
schreibt David Wenk.
Ich finde,
wir haben für eine Reportage
mit sehr vielen Archivaufnahmen
gearbeitet,
gerade, um das sicherzustellen,
um Kontext zu schaffen.
Ich finde,
das ist auch ziemlich gut gelungen.
Auch wenn es kein Film ist, der
primär aus Archivmaterial besteht.
Aber wir haben durchaus noch einmal
die wichtigsten erklärenden Elemente
für die heutige Situation gezeigt,
noch einmal benannt,
noch einmal eingeordnet.
Dann ist die Frage,
welche Fragen sich daraus ableiten.
Es ist ein riesengrosses Thema.
In 30 Min. muss man zwangsläufig
einen Fokus finden.
Unser Fokus war:
Was ist aus dem Traum
von Nelson Mandela geworden?
Dafür haben wir zwei Dinge
speziell betrachtet.
Erstens:
Was ist mit der Landverteilung?
Ist sie gerechter geworden?
Und der zweite Punkt:
Ist die Regenbogennation,
die in Frieden mit sich selbst
und der Welt leben wollte,
wirklich friedlicher geworden?
Wir stellen fest: nein.
Die Kriminalität steigt und
darunter leiden alle Südafrikaner.
Wenn ihr weitere Fragen
oder Anregungen habt,
schreibt es gern in die Kommentare.
Wir nehmen gern dazu Stellung.
Wenn ihr euch für spannende Dokumen-
tarfilme und Reportagen interessiert,
abonniert doch diesen Kanal,
aktiviert die Glocke.
Denn das gibt's hier immer wieder:
spannende Geschichten
aus der ganzen Welt.